welcome to farm Vibes life did you know
that figs aren't actually classified as
a fruit
[Music]
these are upside down flowers providing
a rich source of
[Music]
nutrition hello dear friends and welcome
again many of you may be familiar with
the name figs while some may have never
heard of them before
[Music]
the image below will display as follows
the Fig Tree scientifically known as FAS
Cara is a fruit tree in the family
morer and is commonly grown in tropical
and subtropical regions around the world
fig trees do not flower in the same way
as apple and peach trees they the
flowers bloom inside pear-shaped fruits
which then ripen into the Delicious
Fruit we enjoy in this video we will
delve deal into the cultivation of this
plant in various countries with a
particular focus on the improved fig
growing techniques used in
Japan we will explore the methods of
harvesting and processing figs in
factories with a particular focus on
drying techniques and the health
benefits they
provide let's find out fig trees can be
propagated in a variety of ways normally
this plant is propagated by Farmers by
grafting or cuting cuttings are selected
precisely about 20 to 30 cm bit long and
0.5 to 0.7 cm in thick the farmer
carefully cuts and plants these cuttings
in pots fig trees thrive in both indoor
and outdoor environments spring is the
ideal time for planting once your indoor
fig tree begins to thrive it's time to
transfer the rooted cuting to a larger
pot highquality fertilizers for fig
trees usually contain a balanced
combination of macro and micro nutrients
when planting fig trees Outdoors choose
a time in Springs or early fall and make
sure the tree receives full sun when
choosing a planting site remember that
fig trees have the ability to grow Deep
Roots if given the right conditions
after 3 to four years of planting the
Fig Tree begins to bear
[Music]
fruit fig tree begin to flower and fruit
in early May continuing this cycle until
the first Frost some varieties bear
fruit twice a year once in spring or
summer and again in Fall figs are only
harvested when fully ripe because they
do not ripen further after picking
unlike many other fruits the fruit
should be brightly colored and slightly
soft to the touch the pollination
process of fig trees is extremely
complex characterized by a special
relationship with a small species of bee
called the Fig
bee typically each species of fig tree
is associated with a specific species of
wasp that acts as a pollinator for the
tree the Fig is not a true fruit rather
it is an inverted inflorescence
containing many small flowers contained
within a closed structure the female fig
wasp flies into the infloresence through
a small hole carrying pollen from
another fig tree while searching for a
suitable location to lay eggs the WASP
accidentally pollinates the female
flowers inside after pollination these
flowers will turn into seeds and the
entire structure will develop into a
complete
fig the interdependent relationship
between fig trees and wasps is important
for the trees reproduction and growth as
the presence of wasps is key to the
formation and ripening of figs the
process of harvesting figs in Japan
requires R attention to detail and
precision figs are harvested at Peak
ripeness to ensure the most delicate
flavor and optimal nutritional benefits
each fig is carefully inspected by
workers and only large figs with bright
yellow or red color are selected figs
are carefully arranged in trays to
ensure quality before being transported
to the processing facility
[Music]
figs are collected and transported to
processing facilities where they are
processed into both fresh and dried
products fresh figs are processed
quickly to retain their delicious flavor
and nutritional
value dried sense seam dried figs are
maintained at at a certain moisture
level to retain
nutrients while maintaining their
natural content fresh figs typically
have a soft Center containing many
crunchy seeds this special texture makes
them enjoyable to eat figs offer a
delicious combination of natural
sweetness soluble fiber and many
essential minerals one important mineral
worth
noting especially for growing children
and women is iron dried figs are made by
drying the fruit in natural conditions
usually by stacking them on wooden or
plastic
[Music]
racks they are rich in vitamins and
minerals which offer significant
benefits to people with nutrient
deficiencies dried figs are rich in
antioxidants that help slow down the
aging process dried figs from Japan
contain a variety of vitamins and
minerals especially significant amounts
of potassium and turol these nutrients
play a key role in many of the health
benefits associated with figs including
improved digestion stronger bones and a
reduced risk of chronic diseases dried
figs can be packaged in a variety of
ways depending on the specific type and
grade
[Music]
a favorite treat is figs covered in
premium chocolate providing a special
confectionary experience figs are
growing in popularity in Southeast Asia
and Malaysia is leading the way with the
largest commercial fig plantations in
the region the cultivation of figs in
Southeast Asia has opened up countless
creative opportunities with this
wonderful fruit fig
cultivation has made significant
advances in both technological
innovation and cultivation techniques
Japanese Farmers have adopted modern
agricultural methods to increase fig
production focusing on both quantity and
quality Japan's climate characterized by
distinct Seasons creates the perfect
environment for growing special fig
trees I really appreciate you taking the
time to watch please share your thoughts
in the comments subscribe to my channel
and give this video a thumbs up looking
forward to seeing you next time